hey guys and thanks for tuning in to
another training video today I'm going
to be talking about some of the coolest
home equipment for working out in a home
gym this is stuff that you can buy a
little giving you lots of different
options when you're training from home
and that you can use to actually get a
decent workout there's no reason why you
can't build a lot of muscle burn a lot
of fat training from home you just got
to go about it in the right way you
don't have to spend a fortune either if
you buy the right items then they can
take you a long way in your training
before you need to upgrade or add on to
them so I'm going to go through some
stuff here that's maybe slightly
different from some of the things you
might consider not just your regular
dumbbells and barbells but stuff that
you can maybe get more use out of more
quickly so without further adieu i'ma
show you some of my favorite equipment
for training at home dumbbells
I just said I wasn't gonna go dumbbells
but these are pretty much essential they
do belong in any home gym
they're free like the moment I've got
bad shoulder and I've been using them to
kind of rehabilitate my rotator cuff say
with a pair of dumbbells you can do
pretty much I mean you don't need any
other exes any other equipment at all
basically that's it you do a whole body
workout with dumbbells the only thing
you can't do just body weight for is
your biceps dumbbells solve this problem
nicely because you can obviously do
curls as I talked about in other videos
my favorite way to train with dumbbells
is simply to have them on the floor set
them to a weight that's about the middle
of what you can do for something like
bicep curls then to just do as many
exercises for your target muscle groups
or body workouts
using just the weights on that setting
so you're not wasting time
switching setting this way you can get
in and out of a workout much more
quickly get a much more effective and
efficient a training session how you
like to use a mechanical drop set so
I'll do have a weightless maybe - like
me I'll do as many curls as I can do
underhand grip separated and then I'll
do as many as I can do with a hammer
curl maybe putting in a slight sheet
motion to help myself with momentum but
that way using just dumbbells you can
actually get a really good workout and
you don't even need to change a position
at all so yeah you can do chest
exercises like flies and presses you can
do curls you can do tricep stuff you
don't need anything else but that would
make for a short video so I do recommend
you buy some other stuff because I'll
say it's more fun and interesting so the
kettlebell is basically something you
can use full of baked compound movements
you can use it for the classic little
bell swing let's try not to smash my
camera and that was not you can use it
for overhead presses clean and press
that sort of thing deadlifts of a sort
basically I think this is a great
alternative if you can't get a barbell
because the barbell takes up a lot of
space quite a certain amount of
experience to use and if you're doing
things like deadlifts in your house with
the barbell you might struggle do you
need to carry on training your legs
though and so I think the best thing you
can get for home for training your legs
is a kettlebell also kettlebell is great
for burning fat you can do resistance
card here with it
kettlebell swings done for volume a
great for burning fat so
kettle bell really useful thing also
something I like to do with it there's
100 aber head presses recent being the
big difference bit unique and they only
do for me please because you're using
your obliques to stabilize yourself one
hand favorite headed presses are
underutilized there's something a little
bit different this is a skateboard as
you can probably tell and I've shown in
the past how you can use a skateboard
they're doing all sorts of strange
workouts basically it's great to do an
AB roll and roll outs where you roll
like this with your body but you can
also put your legs on it for kind of
bodyweight hamstring curls you can put
hands on it to do all kinds of unusual
press up variations basically it's a
much more versatile piece of equipment
than you would think so get some
skateboard and watch my video on how to
do it home workout with a skateboard for
more inspiration on that front this is
something else I've talked about before
they say what's good IM jim basically it
fits onto the door frames that you don't
need to put screws into your door which
is very useful because I rent my lamb
I'll probably be very happy if I did
screw into the doorway also it means you
can take it with you you can travel with
it and train at home awesome you can
take it off the door and it means you
can do use it for all kinds of dress-up
variations dips because it becomes
basically like press up stance when you
put it on the floor I use it for a lot
of hand balancing as well I've done
videos on this as well in the past I
also like that it gives you the option
of doing the neutral grip pull-ups like
so and you narrow grip but the only
downside is that for me the the white
pull-ups that I would normally do I
can't do that easily because my dog face
frame is too narrow so I can't get my
hands on it they're something to
consider but otherwise the Iron Gym is a
really awesome piece of equipment most
big manly I think it's gonna collapse
and I'm gonna die but I've had it too
like 6 years and it's never getting ways
it doesn't really versatile piece of
equipment that I highly recommend
decline bench I use this for doing
you locked your legs in there and you do
sit-ups surprisingly hard to get just a
regular bench for um you know doing
dumbbell presses and things like a flat
bench I don't know why
well they don't follow if you do get
them this is folding so it can slide
away under a bed a little bit more
expensive than some of the other stuff
that's still pretty cheap my fingers
like twenty third quit it's really
useful because you can use it to do
sit-ups where you extending the range of
motion although you can get up at the
BOSU ball as well boasting ball and you
can hold a dumbbell or some kind of
other way like this little what liked
kettlebell and from there you're not
only doing the full range of motion with
your abs because that's what the rectus
abdominus force for bending all the way
back and preventing you from and then
letting you bend back forwards and if
you add a weight then you've got
resistance as well and a lot of ab
workouts resistance is really what
they're missing
only weight isn't quite heavy enough so
something like this is awesome and you
can also use it for stuff like PEC flies
decline PEC flies because he's got
dumbbells tricep kickbacks
kneeling bent over rows etc so really
useful little item Sammi right stored
for pretending to be a ninja cardio
workouts they're incredibly dangerous
rope is useful for when you've done your
workout you're tired you feel it
miserable and you want to end it all
also though it can be useful for
attaching to a pull-up bar and then you
can use it for various different things
I use it for tricep bodyweight
extensions push downs like safe you can
also use it for pull-ups that strengthen
your grip like so another way to do the
neutral grip pull-ups and various other
things unfortunately it's a bit narrow
and course on the hands for climbing but
as ever you can do that too generally
it's very versatile it's cost five quid
off ebay and say something to consider
again versatile organized
energy in the world these are stuck
underneath a weight but gymnastic rings
you tap need to put up by Alexei there
you can do dips you do flies you can try
the going cross you can do muscle ups
you can do invert pull-ups push-ups
which is basically a kind of plop
waiting legs still on the ground you
basically do all sorts of really neat
stuff these are again they cost like 10
to 20 quid I think on Amazon and their
billion times better than TRX TRX is
basically these but instead of plastic
rings you get just a piece of fabric
like so also the other difference is the
TRX costs about 100 quid because you get
a calendar and see the awesome Hasini
that you probably watch on YouTube for
free anyways so yeah I'm not bashing TRX
what I am point is you don't need to
spend a hundred quid because to get the
patented TRX because you can get
gymnastic rings for five quid but you
know tons better not five quid 20 quid
still it you know then you can't really
do dips on TRX
you can't believe you muscle ups on TRX
but with these you can do more and the
cheaper by far so really don't waste
your money on that but gymnastic wings
are super useful for doing things like
bodyweight dips which is one of the most
useful and versatile exercises there is
so you get a pull-up bar or a I'm Jimmy
combine it with the gymnastics rings you
basically got a whole body weight
workout you can do there you don't need
anything else but that's the case with
many of these things as a kettlebell
also it's a whole workout in itself so
it's the skateboard point is that I'm
making here this is all the equipment I
have and as you can see here how much
space this is my gym right here and I've
managed to get into you know alright
shake well I didn't get into the shape
of when I get phrases but I managed to
maintain this shape get some good fun
workouts in so pointers you don't need
to spend lots of money you just need to
be smart about how you spend it if you
buy this sort of equipment and if you
use it in the smartest ways then you can
get some awesome workouts from home with
no need
spend money on a costly gym membership
so there you go some of my favorite
pieces of gym equipment that you can try
using or invest in shouldn't set you
back in total more than a hundred quid
probably not even that so give it a go
if you like any of these and if you
enjoyed this video or found it useful
please like share and subscribe comment
and I'll gladly answer you it's very
nice to have a chat thanks very much for
watching stay tuned for more along these
lines as well as all the other brain
training and other stuff that I talked
about bye for now
what I'm getting at Darby is another
muddy